do you [ __ ] your pants
i think i i'm scared let me see i might
do a wiggle let me see
don't is it i can't tell warm is it warm
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and welcome
back to another exciting episode of
truth or dab
the hot one special where we give our
guests two simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last dab
and today i'm excited to welcome benny
blanco and maddie matheson
for more maddie might i suggest just a
dash on youtube and his latest cookbook
homestyle cookery
benny blanco is a five-time bmi
songwriter of the year in his latest
project as friends keep secrets too
together they host eat out america and
stupid [ __ ] cooking show on benny
blanco's youtube channel lots to check
out from these guys but
first a game of truth or dab benny
maddie
welcome to the show thanks for having us
sean
thank you i just don't want to touch my
eye
like i always touch my eyes a lot and i
touch my balls like during
things and i'm very very nervous about
that that's my that's the big that's my
biggest fear
i'm just nervous about um my butthole
because that's the like if it comes out
spicy
there then it's like there's a lot of
trauma and stress
wrapped around that benny we're gonna
start with you today
oh [ __ ] you're one of the most prolific
hit makers of our time we've worked with
the who's who of mega stars
humble brag alert ed sheeran beyonce
rihanna justin bieber just to name a few
what's the story about working with
kanye west that you
actually tell your friends at dinner
parties not the ones that you save for
the press
and maddie you're gonna be the judge on
whether or not
benny's given us that real deal
yeah benny tell the truth okay okay okay
we're in the studio
there's a song called reborn with uh
kid cudi and kanye west and they play
his verse okay
they play the song it's getting bounced
down real time and
he goes stop it stop it i have to hear
the song again
so they're like okay so they're like
play it again and then he's like
run it back one more time and we're like
what's he gonna say is different and
then he just like stops it and he's just
like
well i'm the dopest artist in the world
he's like there's nobody
like he just wanted to tell everyone how
dopey was and it was so
true like honestly it was so true i was
sitting there i was like yeah you're the
dopest guy we're we're an
hour late for a listening thing and
you're stopping it to say how dope you
are and then
we went and we played it it was the
dopest thing in the world he was
honestly right i didn't even fault him
for it
i i i just want to see if benny can lick
the wing just because
i think one lick i want to see you lick
[Music]
it
lick it lick it no like a lip yeah there
let this elevation get in there but no
sit in the chair benny sit in the chair
benny the
opposite can i drink no
go ahead go ahead and drink go ahead and
drink what do i drink what's better for
it
milk go for the milk go for the milk in
times like these
and maddie that laughter might be
short-lived because now the spotlight
moves over to you maddie i want to say
congrats on the programming slate that
you have on your youtube channel which
includes great shows like cooking
something
just a dash and then your podcast power
truth angels
now that you're enterprising on youtube
who is the biggest
diva to work with between me brad leone
and babish follow up what are the
youtube comments that actually bother
you and get under your skin
well great question first of all sean
evans you know
you babbage brad
all you know mega stars you know and and
and uh the thing that's [ __ ] is i
thought
babbage was gonna be such a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i shot with him on the burger show and
the first thing we started talking about
was like garbage plates
and the fact that he's from like
rochester and we got along so
well you though i'll say this everyone
is [ __ ] at night but you
you you and you mentioned it earlier
your scheduling
[ __ ] your scheduling conflict got to
come on eat out america
we had the best [ __ ] hot ones booked
and we did it in a cryo chamber with the
hottest [ __ ]
and then you left you don't you were
just what cleaning your rolexes
like what were you doing
[Laughter]
listen i'm here i'm here to accept that
i i hope that you accept my apology it
is sincere it's one of my great
regrets i could have been puking right
alongside you guys in that very
expensive cryogenic chamber i'm sure
that you guys
lost your deposit on that one benny
we're gonna bounce back to you
of all the music industry titans that
you've worked with in the studio
which one requires the most hands-on
attention and support in order to make a
hit record
first of all matt before i do any maddy
you have to lick your shit's [ __ ]
like you you you said everyone was nice
lick it
i agree oh my whoa okay wow now yeah
it's hot isn't it
yeah it is yeah it's a little hot you
might have to drink some milk
are you drinking homemade i'm drinking
oat milk does oat milk even work
the whole milk is a little bit better
but it is struggle city
it is struggle city as we work through
what do i have to answer who's the
[ __ ] worst i'm not eating i'll tell
you who the [ __ ]
i'm not eating another one i need a spit
bucket
oh i'm 100 answering this uh and it's
and it's little dickies the worst artist
i've ever been in the room with
great guy but we it literally takes us
three years to make a song
i swear every song we've made takes
actually three years
he calls it the no stone unturned method
like i rather eat these chicken wings
every single day and then be in the room
with is that a picture of milk
that's crazy
maddie i know that you take great pride
in being a food
anti-hero and you have called cookbooks
egotistical lament the level of kitchen
perfection that you
often see in traditional food shows as
someone who calls it how you see it
who in your opinion is the most
insufferable
personality on food tv today you want
the [ __ ] heat
you take a bite i'll eat a [ __ ] wing
and anna i don't [ __ ] lie
[ __ ] god no he didn't want to say the
names
you know he's acting like a dumb guy
he's not
in
okay sean what the [ __ ] is going on here
all right we're gonna move on here to
round three
we are cleaning wings we are answering
questions it is just zigging and zagging
over here on truth or dab matty let's
stay with you because okay in addition
to being an author and personality you
also have a lifetime of experience in
restaurants and in kitchens
on the topic of dirty kitchen secrets
what's something that
diners don't want to know about what
actually goes down in the back of house
let me tell you that sean your
nightmares are true
okay oh my god this is so what's the
last
wing i'm selling the last win you want
to know where the [ __ ] bodies are
buried yeah you [ __ ]
you wanna [ __ ] you want okay let me
tell you something
this is so [ __ ] hot this is [ __ ]
you know like those chain restaurants
where
some losers paying twelve dollars for a
20 ounce steak
frozen ass [ __ ] i'm sure some saucy
sus
[ __ ] happens there
it's like waves
i've got a question for you benny from a
songwriting perspective
what's the most embarrassing billboard
top 10 that you've heard incessantly
played on the radio
and say the last decade
he can't say that going in
joining the party are so hot
i like no
oh [ __ ] me you can't die from this can
you
my eyes are hurting i you know my whole
life
i thought this was [ __ ] this show i
thought like everyone
i thought everyone's putting it on i
no that's [ __ ] that last wing even the
last one's [ __ ] up
that last one's [ __ ] up man i can't
i'm like started am i
falling no i know i feel my eyes are
sweating
and i can't hear my ears are
it's so hot and the more you talk the
more oxygen goes in it gets your tongue
all rippled up
it's your turn all right hey maddie
you say your benny blanco fan name three
songs
oh get the [ __ ] out of here he can name
one i know he knows one
for sure east side yeah oh you know one
more he knows one more
i know lonely okay what else hell yeah
you got a name
you got to name a song i produced the
song
[ __ ] one song i produced just like you
you wrote every song in america
like what what do you mean name a song
don't look it up or
ask anyone the uh
did you fireworks no didn't do it that's
the only one
you didn't write fireworks nope let's
give him let's give him one more let's
give him one more okay one more one more
uh the song about ed's irish parents
uh my um my irish my irish parents song
honestly it's close enough i wrote the
irish paris
what's a girl i remember when we
nancy mulligan
all right benny as we mentioned up top
maddie's latest cookbook
is called homestyle cookery what's the
name of his first cookbook
it's the uh the wait the yellow covers
the new one
yes benny okay the
[Music]
this first one called uh yeah
it's literally called what it is it's
called maddie matheson
cookbook are you kidding me yeah i think
i think
you know what if he gives irish parents
i think we give him
cookbooks maddie matheson
a cookbook oh my god oh my
i just i really think your [ __ ]
did you show your pants i think i'm
scared let me see
i might do a wiggle this let me see
don't is it
i can't tell it's warm i is it warm
it really slipped out i was coughing
on that note i think that we've reached
the finish line of today's episode
maddie matheson benny blanco what a wild
ride it was is there anything that you
want to say to the fans before we send
you guys off to a cryogenic freezer
we love you we love you
all of the fans uh thank you for
everything you've done for us
me and benny i want to take that sheeran
i wanna i wanna i wanna thank
uh kanye who's everyone that benny's
worked with
because benny benny's such a beautiful
person and he's so sweet
he's such a little baby angel look it up
look at him
this sucks this sucks this sucks
this sucks for people we don't even get
paid
i got one for you sean okay
worst worst person that's ever been on
the show that you did you didn't even
want on who's the biggest [ __ ] yeah
who's the biggest [ __ ] biggest
[ __ ] you know what
i'm gonna i'm gonna keep that a mystery
i'm going to keep that one a mystery
i'll hit you
i'll hit you on text
shake it keep shaking yeah there is a
name popping around i'll hit you on text
benny
wait i have one last question sean i
have one last question what is happening
when are you coming on eat out america
oh yeah when are you coming on
when you're scheduled to open up yeah
we'll open up you're alone in a room
i am ready i am ready to go i'm ready
next time you guys want me i am there
that is a promise i don't even care if i
want
i'm on call you guys sound the alarm i'm
there
how many rolexes do you own just this
one
get him another one first we feel 10
million are you [ __ ]
get him another one 10 million subs
because of this [ __ ] get him
another watch
come on get him a watch
hot ones truth or dab the game the kick
comes complete with 250 question cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table
you take turns being the host being the
players
and when you're a player and you get
asked a question you have a choice just
like in the show
answer it honestly or suffer the wrath
of the last dab and take a look at this
there's even a mini bottle of the last
dab included i suggest you have napkins
on hand
you have to have some milk on hand and
of course be careful be very careful
around the eyes hot ones truth or dab
the play at home game is available at
shop.firstweekfees.comheatness.com and
amazon play at your own risk wings
not included